you guys are going to be completely
shocked right now because every now and
again something same happens or at least
roughly saying happens on CNN and Van
Jones who is sometimes sane sometimes
completely insane he I think he sort of
said something same here related to all
all of this I mean I'm throwing this up
at the channel does this hurt the other
cases uh right now being pursued I I
worry I mean look if this is the only
Pebble that gets thrown at Donald Trump
uh it's a very small pebble if it's the
first Pebble in an avalanche of other
indictments that strike more to the
heart of I think people's core concern
about Donald Trump which is his threat
to democracy so this is the first Pebble
the next one is about the election
interference in Georgia the next one is
about the the the the the coup the
Insurrection January 6th the next one's
about him hoarding these documents and
why then it begins to fit but if this is
the only Pebble it's not much of a
pebble and I do think it could uh uh the
backlash against this Pebble Mike cow
other people who might otherwise have
been courageous enough to step forward
I've got to say two observations first
to list this point you know today this
this morning we saw he had an away game
in a very unfriendly Stadium right
tonight he's got a home game in front of
a home crowd who are riled up it is it's
like a homecoming he'll be he'll be
he'll be jubilant
I should qualify my own remarks you know
sometimes van Jones says something sane
but he also is saying insane things at
the same time the core concern that most
people have is Donald Trump's threat to
democracy I mean I think half the
country right now thinks the other side
is a threat to democracy let's just put
that out there uh but my point on the
sanity side was that if this is the only
Pebble meaning that he's arguing in a
way that this isn't that much John what
do you think of the the case itself
right now these 34 charges it sounds
like most of them should have been
misdemeanors they've been boosted to
felonies you know we got Stormy Daniels
now what was Trump money the whole thing
is so confusing well well let me tell
you what the biggest problem is with
this case first of all the case is a big
nothing right I don't see how this ever
survives uh an appeal on the statute of
limitations issue alone but but here's
how Preposterous the 34 counts are there
they've charged 34 counts on the same
payout because it was done in
installments so when I worked in a
robbery interdiction unit this is
equivalent to me arresting someone for
for armed robbery they walk into a
bodega in Queens Jeff and they stick a
gun in the in the clerk's face and they
get 100 bucks out of the register but
instead of me charging one count of
robbery in the first degree because the
clerk counted out 10 10 bills for the
hundred bucks I charge 10 counts of
robbery the D.A would laugh at me and
knock it down to one count for a hundred
bucks so that alone is preposterous and
I'll go as far as to say unprecedented
but I do think Georgia and the FEDS are
going to come with subsequent
indictments that might have a little bit
more meat this New York case to me is
frivolous nonsense now a New York City
judge is never going to dismiss this I
should say it's 98 chance they won't
dismiss it Anything could happen but I
don't see how this could ever survive on
an appeal
like more sane takes on our insane World
check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live round tables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell